let's return to our top story now and
the earthquake in Morocco Al jazeer is
joins us now from Marrakesh Abdullah
first of all tell us about the rescue
operations are they still pulling people
out alive from the rubble how's it
looking at this point
well Sammy the search and the rescue is
still going on it's a Race Against Time
because
very of of many factors basically to try
and see if there is still survivors
under the rebels and also because it's a
Muslim country to bury the dead the and
to avoid that the Dead the bodies start
you know
disintegrating and maybe causing
something something else other than the
impact the huge impacts caused by this
by this earthquake in six provinces here
the earthquake was felt in the whole
almost in the Hall of Morocco but it
impacted directly six provinces the
province of Marrakesh the province of
azilal province of shishawak the
province of that province of tarot and
mainly the province of our house this is
the most
hated the strongest hated the strongest
hit happened there the epicenter of the
of the of the earthquake was there
now the aftermath of this what happened
is even right now we are now the third
for the fourth day after after the
earthquake and still people in Marrakesh
not only the the people who've
more or less lost their homes or their
homes are uh you know about to fell down
or were damaged by the earthquake but
also people who are out of fear are
preferred and you can maybe see some of
them behind me here they they they spend
the nights in in public gardens in
public squares like this one
of the Ministries and these people
they've been sleeping here some of them
have left
yeah what I recall covering the
earthquake in turkey at this point after
three nights when people have been out
little things start to become big
challenges the challenge of things like
taking a shower even getting a fresh
pair of underwear was one that I would
hear a lot from people the cold heating
how are people is anyone helping people
with stuff like that
there are some of course some of the
services that depends of the local
authorities and also some some uh Civil
Society associations who are helping
people with that but right and Marrakesh
is a is a hot a hot City you know the
weather is hot in Marrakesh usually and
the whole region here but uh the the
next problem that starts started
actually this night is that there is a
drop in the well in the in the in the uh
in the temperature
during the nights I I spent the the the
night before this one the the night
Saturday to Sunday night I spend it
doing lives like this one and I wasn't
wearing this sleeveless jacket today I
wear this because weather temperature
has dropped if
the temperature has dropped in here in
Marrakesh
you can only imagine what is it now
in the mountains
so this is the new challenge that that
comes
and it's added to that Race Against Time
that the Moroccan authorities with all
its apparatus are engaged in engaged in
right now to try and finish their search
and rescue and to try to finish also uh
the the camps that are surrounded by the
military and the hospitals in there the
the the the the the hospitals camps
hospitals
in order to start you know cleaning the
the areas and of course go to the next
phase which is the rebuilding
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much